We have some space. That's
a good picture though. No,
cause you know what it is is then if
you're sitting there then we have to
fucking be like that. It's
a consistent angle thing.
It's definitely an angle thing.
All right, we're going, hey,
what's going on and spilled. Burn.
It's time for a very special edition
of the Monday morning podcast.
I don't even know when the fucking gonna
put this out probably before Monday
because a, my guest, um,
his series is already
three episodes in and uh,
he was supposed to be on two weeks ago
and I completely spaced big Hollywood
phony that I am at a very fitting that
he came back again in the name of his
show is the return of the Mack
as he's returning to the podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen, Joe Attire.
Thank you too. Sorry man. Uh,
it's okay. I knowing you,
I know that you were, you,
you felt you felt bad about it, so it,
and you made me feel worse cause you
were a fucking sweetheart. [inaudible]
I was going like, Joe, can you at least
get mad at me? Like, oh, it's fine.
I needed. He goes, I needed to get out
of the house. Yeah, I'm says that. No,
I was, I was hanging. It was all good
dude. It was all good and thank you.
Thank you. And I know, I know that, uh,
you know that you don't have a
lot of cats, you know what I mean?
So it's special. So thank you for
[inaudible] just fucking guilt trip dude.
Do you know this to your wife? This
is brutal. Now I know, you know,
you're gonna be looking at people and
it's kind of the Boston thing too,
you know what I mean? Cause we're,
we're good with the guilt thing,
you know what I mean? So we can,
we can just let that thing hang over
your head forever. You know what I mean?
For years and years and years.
But I ended up putting on,
I don't do that because I wouldn't have
seen your show exactly. Cause I was,
you know, I was busy doing
a bunch of shit. Right.
And then I'm sitting there and I have
like a panic attack. I'm like, oh my God.
Like, I fucking stood this guy up. I said
I was gonna be there. I wasn't there.
And I go, now I got to watch your
shows. Like what if I don't like it? Oh,
how fucking brutal is this? Like
half hour, 45 minutes can be.
Fortunately I watched it and
uh, it's fucking hilarious man.
Thank you man. Really Fun. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank, I know I, I've,
I've got a few friends that said
that like, Ooh, it ain't gonna save.
I don't like it, but uh, uh, it, it is
good. It is good. You know, when you,
you make something,
you kind of all in it and to get some
perspective and actually see it on a,
you know, a, a TV and it's, it's
nice. I, I feel certain, a lot of,
you know, it's a sense of
accomplishment and what I couldn't find.
What network is it on? Cause we record
the thing. So it's on, it's on pop TV.
It's not on the comfy channel.
And now the comfy channel,
that's the channel within the show.
Yeah. Um, yeah, it's on pop TV,
which is, it's a CBS lion's
gate partnership, but it's,
it's the channel's been up for
about two years. Um, it's on most,
I think every carrier has it. Sometimes
it's on like a, you know, a higher tier,
so it's not basic. Uh, which is kind
of a bummer sometimes. So, you know,
on one sense, you know, there's not a
ton of expectation, you know what I mean?
And you can build and
hopefully the networks like,
oh well wait know it's going to, you just
going to build it takes a second. Um,
what a crazy though.
How I'm like, you know,
when we were coming up there was just,
you could find shows and now it's like,
do you know my parents,
my parents have never seen my show cause
it's on Netflix and they don't know how
to get on it. It's just, I'm
like, you got to have a password.
You've got to like grab the
other remote control, do this.
It's like they have no idea. Um,
that's why when I take my specials,
they come to the special cause I know
they're not going to be able to find it
once it gets on Netflix, it just, you
know, that's the only way they see it. Um,
I do, I do tweet you. I,
I mean I do text you when I see
that beautiful Mug of you on, on,
on billboards across Los Angeles,
and then you treat me a picture of
me and like big bopper and in 1988,
you know what I mean? Just to get me
better. Give me shit though. Yeah. Well,
you know I gotta I know you go, we get
it. You got a special, what's that? Fuck.
That's the way you come at me,
which is why I was surprised when I,
when I didn't show up that
you were still, uh, oh yeah.
So He's going back. How
I originally met Joe was,
we worked on a movie called the
heat. Yes. Believe it or not,
that was up coming up on five years ago.
We filmed a five years ago and
we had a great time on that.
And it's another one of your cas men or
members? Jenny Denver was on that thing.
Yup. Return to the Mac.
Yes. Um, we, uh, that was,
that was sweet. I mean that Gig was
sweet Paul fake movie, big movie.
We were in our home town. Me and nick
met me in a, I sit the Nate Caudrey, uh,
who was, who was in it as well recently.
I said it's known as three
weeks in August. Like that said,
it has its own name. You know, for
me it was just a lot in my north end.
It was lovely. It was a lovely
experience. And obviously,
when did you leave Boston? Um, well I
was in New York for a while. You know,
I realized after new
kids broke up, you know,
I woke up when I was
like 21, and I was like,
the biggest decision I had to make was
where I was having lunch. And I was like,
okay, I gotta I gotta do something,
you know what I mean? Like,
and I'm wait [inaudible]
that whole thing broke up.
You took the whole Ryan and was done
by the time you were 21? Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean I was 15 when we
had our first hit records,
so that was like 88 and
then we had like, you know,
four or five years and then Kurt Cobain
came along and it was, what was it?
It was all, it was weird does then
it started back up again. Yeah.
In the late nineties thousand eight when
Kurt killed himself and he wasn't there
to stop those boy beds. Yeah, exactly. Um,
no, we, we, yeah,
we've been back together since
2008 but our fans have grown up.
You know what I mean? We, we look
back on that, but you know, with,
with an open heart and the nostalgia
and all that stuff, when we embrace it,
and right now we're just like a girls
night out for our fans. You know,
they get to get away from it. But yeah.
You kinda touch on that in the show
where I noticed that you have like,
you keep having these really
awkward moments where these,
like with the overly like, yeah, sex up
women, you know? Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah, yes. Yeah, that's true.
Does that happen to you along like they
want to give you a long little too long
of a hug. I don't want you to shit on
your fans and just say, oh, we have all,
you know, shapes and sizes. There's
a few, there's a few that I'm,
dude, you sound like
you're running for office,
then you're not going to get in
trouble in this city to me, you know,
can't blame me there. We're still playing
arenas. So like you say, I got it. No,
you gotta take care of my, my fans.
Absolutely. I've said the right thing,
but no, some, some are a
little too little too, uh,
you know, aggressive or, you know,
touchy feely. You know what I mean?
But that's okay. For the
most part, they're, they're
fine. But yes, but, but I,
so, so I left,
so I spent some time in New York and
then I've been out in la for 15 years and
kind of get nichey for the, to go back
to go back east to do, you know, it's,
it's the best here. But,
um, it's funny when I,
when I think of my friends who are
that, you know, have had babies,
you get, you know, you get how old
you? A little five, three months,
three months, little over three. And
it's hopeful, you know what I mean?
It's really funny is like in, you
know, not to get all, you know,
it's a tough time in the world
and it's crazy, whatever, but,
and it's so cliche,
but it's like really hopeful when someone
has a baby because for you it's all
about that kid, man. I mean, what's
more hopeful than a new kid? You know?
And you're just like, you know, and
it's, and it's really nice. I'm a mom.
My kids are almost six, seven and nine,
so it's a little bit of a different
vibe. But, um, anyways, I'm,
I don't feel like, you know what I feel
like weird about how uh, once I left,
all of a sudden they all to every team
starts winning championships and as much
as so much fun it is to be behind any
enemy lines. Like Celtics beat the Lakers.
I was out here and red sox beat the
Yankees. I was in New York but you know,
I recently did a show, uh,
and an acting gig actually
one day back in um,
Boston and I remember the Bruins were
just starting to play offs and was looking
at my hotel window and I just saw a sea
of Bruins jerseys and just to finally be
like, oh my God,
I could actually wear them cause I don't
wear any of my shit out here. It just,
people are nuts on the west coast. They
take it to a whole other level. It's,
it's violent, it's got it. It's not
fun. Like when I was in New York,
it was fun. It was ball breaking.
I even been in Philly and you know,
as much as they hiked those guys up, it's
like you got to go out of your way to,
to really get an ASCA, you're
definitely going to get shit.
You might get something dumped on
you, but that's as far as it goes.
But out here, yeah, it's just
like a, it's like Mad Max at,
you're a little scared for your life.
Yeah. I mean, I was at the 2010, uh,
when the, when the Lakers did
beat the Celtics and I was,
I when they called 58 fouls on the
Celtics and like 12 on the, that's great.
That's great. For a game
seven, it was fun to watch.
The Lakers beat us from
the foul line. That's,
that's always good for hoop
and they barely won. You're
right. Even without our,
our, our center. But um, I'm
not saying we would have one,
but I'm just saying it's like you
gotta like you gotta let them play,
let them fucking play. What's
the most anticlimactic that,
the one memorable moment, that game
that I can only remember was Ron,
our test hitting at three. That
was a fucking huge shot. Yeah. But,
and it was ugly. Other than
that, it was an ugly game sense.
There was no magic with the baby sky hook.
There was always like a moment bird
steals the ball or something like that.
It was like, Nah, they just, a Colby
didn't have a good game that, that game,
you know, I remember him saying
after the game, he was like, I can't,
I don't know how we won
that game. It's like, well,
fucking talk to the footlocker
guys because those are the MVPs.
They switched out the footlocker
guys and the, you know,
they're ready to happen. The
last, uh, Boston Cleveland game.
Not Cleveland game. Sorry. Who the fuck
are we playing? Uh, bulls. The Bulls,
the last, last bulls game,
like I thought the Fisher
gang was terrible and it
was in our favor and I loved
when Lopez did this. Like the
sarcastic, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was when you, then you saw it.
Then they went down the
court and then Dwayne,
Dwayne Wade got a ticky textile one and
he was like laughing going like no one,
it was like a makeup called, but it was
like too late at that point, so. Right,
right, right. All right. I'm good sir.
I mean we got the luck of the draw
there with Rondo getting hurt.
So it was the MVP of the series I
think easy because even still because,
because he's still the most
valuable cause he's first game.
It looked like they were going to sweep
us and all of a sudden he was gone.
I know, I know. He was asked. He
was in his house. You think he is?
I think that he's going to make
six came sasters off. Okay.
He's got long sleeves on his sport
coat. Again, not tripping anybody.
You see him trip up a, what's his
name? Crowded crowd. I thank you.
I love when he tried to
act like he was stretching.
He was totally like looking right
at him. I thought it was funny.
And then he says in the press committee,
he's like, Oh yeah, I've got a ACO.
And I just, uh, like to stretch it.
Next question. And he was $25,000,
and then he goes, he was really way out
of bounds. He tried to put it on him.
Yeah. Yeah. Dad Dead Pan face. I actually,
I liked, I thought it
was funny. It was not,
I mean I don't give a shit about it.
God was going to break his fucking leg
over that he sort of stuck it out. He,
he's the kind of guy you want on your
team, but he's not on a team anymore.
Right. And then he tried to push, you
know, rail and out of the big, uh, did he,
did you see that story where
that they haven't like a reunion,
a 10 year reunion for the Celtics,
but like a year earlier
or something like that,
they're all going to The
Bahamas or something like that.
And they didn't invite Ray Allen
because he went to the Miami Heat.
You know something too.
I never understood that too because it
was like him going to Miami, Miami Heat.
That's how we got him. He was
a sonic. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
So if you sign a free agent like, and you,
it's like I've joked to my pockets that's
like falling in love with a stripper.
Yeah. There's no loyalty at that
point. It's just like, fuck it,
I'm going to get paid and try to
win rings. And he, he, what was he?
He was there three, four years. I mean,
it just, to me it's a personality thing.
That's what I love about sports the most.
Like you can talk about the
x's and o's and all that stuff,
but like the personalities man. I
mean, you look at Lebron like for me,
the way it is and how they sit and why
they sit and why they rest and should
they, you know, they getting paid
millions and millions of millions of
dollars in there sitting there resting.
It's like, oh well they're tired. Well,
the other team's tired too. Right.
You know, so it's a, and I just love
that. I just think he's like, the Bron is,
I call him the greatest player ever to
not want the ball at the end of the game.
No, that was him before. Before
they want it. When he's on the,
he doesn't want the ball
at the end. It's still,
I'm not saying he's not amazing.
He does not want the ball
at the end of the game.
I kind of re Irving does.
I thought he pushed through that when
he was with the heat. He Won. He Won.
If he can go, he won. He Won. Yeah. Um,
but he just, yeah, it's a, it's an eye,
you know, and I'm not hating on him.
I think he's an amazing, you know,
athlete and person and all that stuff.
I just think he's, he does it
all the greats. Larry Bird,
I say Thomas Colby at
the, all those Jordan,
of course they wanted the ball.
Everyone get out of my way.
That's not him and I, it's, it's,
it's intriguing to me. Yeah.
I thought he was that until like, uh,
once he won it with the heat and all of
a sudden I remember he was playing some
game was the end of the game and he
actually took the shot and missed.
But the fact that he did it, I've
thought that he pushed through.
You got him up too.
He came into the League at 18 I just
think there was all this expectation,
that type of thing, and I think it took
them a minute to kind of grow into it.
But I, I think, I think
he's, he's past that.
Then you take the last fricking shot to
win it last year. No, that wasn't him.
No, no. He ran down. He blocked
the ball. No, I meant exactly,
but that's what he'll do. Well, that was,
you're supposed to take
a whole court show. No,
but he overcompensates and these
superhuman ways with that block,
but it, he does not want the fall.
I've never seen a guy so good.
Gets so much fucking shit. I
don't know what it is. Well,
some people might think I'm hating on him.
I'm saying you just call him the greatest
defensive plays and won the biggest
moment of the biggest fucking game.
Yes. As underdogs. He turns it off.
You said it was overcompensating.
I'm not well heat.
That's hitting a little
bit. I'm going to say, oh,
he makes up for not wanting the ball
at the end of the game. I can't listen.
If he takes the ball and gets it on
the buzzer beater, I'll be thrilled.
I'll be thrilled. I'm not hating
him. I'm not saying he's not capable.
You won't be thrilled if he goes against
the Celtic. She wouldn't be. To me,
it's fascinating that someone
that talented still has
room to grow or stuff they
haven't done. All right. That's
fair enough. Hey Joe, fair enough.
Back to my TV show. Back to
you. No, I'm kidding. Kidding.
How much of that is Improv a not a
lot, actually. Not a writing's not. No,
thank you. Yeah, I co-created it
with, uh, my friend Paul Greenberg,
who I was introduced to by Donny Walberg
and Jenny McCarthy who are also on the
show. Oh yes. Hilarious. Yes, yes.
They're executive producers as well.
So Paul and I,
and then there was a Heather Rutman
and a Mike Glock or a writers.
And uh, so it was a small
writing team, but you know,
you have three days to shoot,
so you don't really have a
lot of for each episode. Wait,
you shoot that in three days.
Three days by how many can
we do two episodes at a time?
So it's over six days.
We do a two episodes.
So how can we have a [inaudible]
two? We have three. No,
we had two cameras. And tell
me how long have you days.
Not Super Long because
that gets into over time.
And that's a budget thing too with I
learned a lot who just started showing it,
right? Yeah. So how long did it
take you to shoot? Six. Ah, so us,
oh six you mean six episodes?
Well, we did eight episodes a day.
So it was a three. It was
24 days. It was 24 days.
And um, which is I, I love
it. I mean that's forced,
can grade you want more, you know, be
nice to have, you know, Mama, you say,
oh it's fine and I want more.
But like maybe if there was a second
season you want a little bit more dough to
do this or do that. But as far as
an actor and getting out there,
you don't need that much time. You
know, you have four or five to,
I never felt like we didn't have
enough time to get the takes,
but to your point about, uh, you know,
uh, at, you know, adlibbing or improving,
we, we didn't have a lot of time to
just go there. So the scripts were good.
I grade, I, I was really happy
with them and, and um, you know,
it is a little bit here and there, but
for the most part I was scripted. Yeah.
Yeah. That's the way to do a show.
I've worked with a few people that
knew like a, the always sunny guys,
those guys like you ever seen how
they, they'll shoot this season,
like they have it all mapped out, so
they'll like do for like the whole season,
like all the bar things and
then just their, yeah, shoot.
It all run out changed and they just
do like, it's genius how they do it.
And then there's other shows that you go
on and it's just like you're doing like
14, 16 hour days and like you literally
want to kill I, yeah, paint dry.
Yeah, exactly. And I was just like,
I don't think I ever want
another acting gig in my life.
This is fucking horrific. And uh, I
always call it like those types of shoots.
Like people say, what are those
things? Like I say, compared to,
it's like going to the DMV
with like famous people.
So he's just sitting
around the same thing,
just sitting there thinking you're
never, never going to get called.
And then when you finally do you fucking
elated. And uh, I, it's, I don't know,
I've heard like stories of like actors
like learning how to play instruments.
Just sitting around waiting
in there. Yeah, in the, yeah.
And I know it's like you hate to
complain about a Gig, but it's true.
You're in it, you're in a, you're in a
trailer and you're in your same thing.
It's like, this is what I worked for.
Like this is what I want. And, and,
and it's not a coincidence. It'll
work. Like I want to go there and work.
Exactly. Some fucking
reason sitting around. It's,
it's, I actually understood my dog better.
It's like I get why when my
dog is just laying there,
it goes to sleep because your
body's lily like, alright,
well we're not doing shit.
Let's save up this energy.
You start nodding off like an old man
and the second you start to sleep,
you're going to get that knock on
your door. Now you fell asleep.
You're not going to be fucking in it
and they bring you out. I were gone,
but we have a quick, we're
losing. Yes. I'm like, yes.
It's more like a mentally look.
It's way better than fucking
roofing in June and July. Exactly.
I lasted like three weeks doing that
shit. But I'm just saying like, um,
you know what it is to me
it's the frustration is when
you're there it's like it
doesn't have to take this fucking
long. Yeah, no it doesn't. But that's,
he know what you're doing.
It doesn't have to take this fucking
long sliding stuff and everything in it.
And I guess you can see the
difference in some, you know,
the production value and,
and that's fine. But I,
I agree and that's why it's,
it's in my nature to go,
you know what I mean?
I got lucky a lot of people trying to
make TV shows in this town and like I'm
super grateful, but like I, I was like,
I wanted to get active and do it and,
and we were able to get it done and yeah,
but when word gets out it, you know,
people see how funniest show is and
that you guys shoot it that quick.
Like I don't think you'll have a problem
getting people doing guest stars.
I think so. I think so. I'm going
to quote you a bell. There you go.
You just set yourself up and plus you
see your shrewd businessman.
You waited and Adam, the guilt.
Adam loves you by the way, out
of Marae, uh, as so many do.
But he was on the,
you guys just did a charity
Gig and he went on before you,
and I think you will
like this guy, you know,
you were very cupboard like this guy
should closed. What am I doing with them?
This guy set a, that was foolishness.
Exactly. Exactly. Yeah, exactly.
So, uh, yeah, he fucking murdered.
Yeah, he's, he's, he was, uh,
it's one of those things where you
say, I, I wrote for that person,
like when I wrote the, the first
pilot, like I was just writing for him,
you know what I mean? I was just
getting off on, on his whole vibe.
He's super charming. Guy
Loves, I mean works a ton. And,
and uh, and we had a blast
doing guest stars too.
I saw it like the third episode, Joey
Fatone joyful murder. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
man. He's, he's a funny bastard, so I,
yeah, and he's really silly doesn't,
he doesn't like he just
exactly. Self deprecating.
And then the Chris Kirkpatrick
who was also from INSYNC,
he comes in at the end of
episode three and, and he, uh,
he really throws himself
under the bus. You know,
normally you have a guest star
and you've got to let them win.
You know what I mean? Yeah. But he
comes up in episode five and he really,
you know, goes forward. So I said,
you have all these guys on here and it's
great cause that you let them do what
they're going to do. So
you get to see how talent,
like Joey Lawrence murdered it.
But yeah, no, he was great. Again,
he's sort of like America's sweetheart,
but I knew a different side of him.
A real ball buster. Like
acerbic super funny.
He's super talented, been around
forever. But I knew when we went at it,
you know, doing that thing, it
would be, you know, super funny.
And he was great. We had a blast
doing it too. So now is that true?
Did you guys both come in third
place? We did. We did. So I did.
The thing is I, I want people, most,
a lot of people forget cause I did the
first season of dancing with the stars
and I didn't want to do it. Man. I want
it to be totally through that. Okay.
You're sitting there, you need a Gig.
This is like an episode of your show
when your agent calls up. Joe. Totally.
I got to get, got it. Yeah. So it was
just out the pilot season. I actually,
I just did six months
on Broadway in wicked,
very early on with the
demons l like, you know,
x height of like what I,
what I love to be doing.
But I had it in my mind like a rookie.
I'm going to go out to La
and book a pilot. Right.
Just to book a pilot just for
my ego, not because of the work,
not because of the right
project. You know what I mean?
So I was in it for the wrong
reasons. So people open to uh,
seeing you for stuff? Yeah. I mean,
about a year or so before that I was on
a David Kelly show as as a regular on
Boston public. That lasted
for about three years.
I was on it for a year and it changed my
life. I came out to La, I met my wife.
So things happen. You're
like, you needed, you needed,
you had to get one of those gigs to
separate you from all this guy's,
he's in a band, his little band, the
whole thing. And I just thought it would,
you know, change my life or whatever.
I, I'd be cool on my ego. It's just,
I thought that was it. It was
Christmas. And so I had a bad, you know,
pilot season as you know, so many
lives. Do you know what I mean?
Everybody does. Like now I
know. Now I know everybody,
no matter how good you are, you know what
I mean? Like it's a, it's a crapshoot.
So I get this call for tents with this
British guys. Like it's a beautiful,
it's unbelievable. It's,
it had some other name and the UK
and it's going to be great. And,
you know, don't worry, you
win and that whole thing and,
and we won't make you look bad. Yeah. I
was like, great for your Korea. Exactly.
And I was like, I said no a million times.
And then I said yes and no and yes and no.
And literally I'm up in my bed over
how long a period of time is all these
notes. And yesterday, maybe a week or
two, three agonizing over, hey, agonizing,
right. Cause this is not what I want to
do. I don't want to do a reality show.
We didn't know what dancy with
the stock and it's all relative.
Some people I talk about this and
they go, what's wrong with it?
It stands out with the stars. It's the
biggest show on TV, but to each his own,
you know what I mean? It's not what
I wanted to do. But anyways, I, I,
I was up in bed. I was like, after
I almost like signed the contract,
I was like, I can't do it
because I was in, you know,
the joke is like I get
up in bed and I'm like,
I'm in a dance contest with
their Vander Holyfield.
What the fuck am I doing?
What am I doing? And,
and I just couldn't say no. And
a house was on that season. Uh,
Rachel Hunter, um, or
whatever. John O'Hurley,
John O'Hurley from Jay
Peterman. We talk about that in,
in my show in episode two. And, um,
another girl from a general hospital
and um, I'm blanking. So they were all,
they were all a mess. I was a
dancer, so they had to take me down.
It's a produce show,
so they're gonna cut me out at the
knees from day one to get the storylines
going. You know what I
mean? So, wait, so when,
how did they take you out on the show?
So all these people can, the dance,
you can, this is what the fuck you
been doing your whole life, Joey.
That was all full. You look like and
scabbed me and said, riling rally,
dad's flock. They said, oh
yeah, yeah, they murdered me,
they murdered me and I kicked ass. Yeah.
So now how did you hold your
component? Like you're standing there.
They're filming. Go to the tape.
I mean right now, but yeah,
I need to sit in there
like these mother fuckers,
I don't want you to track but oh no, I
don't care. I don't care at this point.
I mean it's a joke now. I'm, I'm, I'm,
and that's why I was able
to use it in the show.
Like the guy who got Scott and miss.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Literally said, he said.
And so, you know, I, I, I'm, I'm
attached from it now and, and,
and I'm able to use
that stuff for my show.
Like the guy I play on my show now
returning the Mac is, is, is that guy,
you know what I mean?
Who couldn't say no who didn't have
the patience or the integrity or the
discipline to ride it out
for the right part. Now.
That's why I like watching your
show because I see this other side,
like your home life and stuff.
Yeah. Even you getting like the uh,
the person to help with your kids.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's shit that I do. I know
honey. Whoever you, whoever you want,
that's fine. That's fine. Fortunately,
no, that's worked out in my life.
But I mean, yeah, exactly.
Until, until you know,
you get some crazy guy and then
you weigh in definitely until,
till your wife gets it wrong.
Whatever you need until what the
hell were you thinking? You know? Um,
but I'm sorry, I interrupted
a great story. So you know,
so you're sitting there,
they're saying you go like a
Scud missile all over the place.
I just didn't want to do this show but
we, it was six episodes. People still go,
why don't you do dancing with
the stars? And I think to myself,
should I tell them I did
it? Whatever. Cause like it,
my ego says I like when people forget
that I did that show cause it's not really
what I wanted to do on the
other side. It's like, hey,
it's all Shope is in, in life.
Things happen and you learn from them.
How many, how many weeks did you do?
Well, it was only six weeks
back then. Cause it was the,
it was a summer program. They were
given a shot by six weeks. The finale,
that was like 15 million
people watching it.
So I'm at 50 million people. So
you come in third. Yeah, St Luke.
Did you lose two? Evander Holyfield
hate. No, I beat a Vander. Holy field.
Got a lot of people can say that.
That's a tough man. But, but, but, but,
but exactly. Exactly. But
John, John O'Hurley loved it.
Guys in his sixties he's doing
the walls, he's eating it up,
they're loving and he's eating
the scenery. You know what I mean?
Like God bless them. This was, I'm
sensing insight. Spark in your eyes.
I haven't seen any years. Exactly.
It was brilliant and good for him.
You know what I mean? He had a blast
and, and I learned a lot too. I mean,
I learned, you know,
how to do that kind of dancing and you
learned from the dancers and dancers in
this business, especially on Broadway,
are the hardest working people in show
business because they got a dance.
You know, most of them have to sing
on Broadway. They'd dance and sing.
Their egos are like totally in
check. They come to work everyday,
they don't complain and it's the
stars and the leads that, you know,
do all the complaining
when they really have,
it's so much better than everybody
else. Right. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
So what was the fallout of that?
So after that, uh, you come in,
how did you take, when you, we relieve
when you got kicked off the show?
At that point? We just, our well was
kind of, I think I got episode five,
I was gone and then they
had me back for the finale.
Everybody was there for the finale. Um,
you know, I, I felt like I went out,
you know, I, I, I was good with
my performances, but again,
they took me down cause they
needed a storyline. I mean,
that's kind of what that, that's my story
anyways. But, um, it was cool. I mean,
I actually did a, a standards
album after that and, um,
we went on tour and we, I feel like
I got a little something out of it,
you know what I mean? We went on like a,
an arena tour and funny enough that
actually, um, that's how I met, uh,
the new kids manager at the time we
were managing and I talked to Donny,
Donny and I were talking about
getting together and I said, well,
this might be the manager because
I've been working with this guy.
So it's that kind of thing. You'd do
things that you think aren't right,
but you're there,
you make the most of it and it could
lead to big that that led to you guys
getting back together. Well, a small
piece, a lot of things have to happen,
you know what I mean? Started putting
that thing back together, like going,
fuck a 40 people gonna
show up. Yeah. Well,
the cool thing was that we were, we were
in it together. I mean, we were, if,
if these other four guys were willing to
get in the foxhole and see what happens
because we have so much history
together and we're like family,
you know what I mean? So that was
the cool part, you know what I mean?
And I trusted those guys.
I mean, Donny, you know,
I felt like he always held our,
what we had very dear to women, like
when, when MTV or VH one would go,
come on our talent, come
on our awards show, they,
they wanted their big ratings hit,
they wanted their five minutes.
And we always like, hey man, we're,
we're bigger than five minutes.
You know what I mean? And sure enough,
the timing was right and we did it the
right way and our fans showed up for us
and you know, we back in
arenas have to, you know, jam.
You guys did like Fenway
or Clark too, right?
You'll be doing family park July 8th
again, man, don't it again. Yeah. Cool.
Yeah. So cool man. That's so
cool. That's great. So we got,
you've got five more
episodes coming out. Um,
so you're gonna get back to
Boston. Um, what's your deal man?
Are you going to like stay out
here? Um, I know. Well, uh,
we'll see. We'll see about the, you know,
second season, you know how that goes.
But, um, I dunno,
I don't know if I'm just
distracting myself by saying
I want to like get back to
New York or Boston. Uh, it's so nice
out here. You actually have like a yard,
you know what I mean? In New York
is just a totally different thing.
My wife's from New York, but it's high
class problems, but I'm just Kinda like,
I dunno if I'm just need something
to chew on, you know what I mean?
Or if I'm like to relax, you know what
I mean? Just your here be where you are,
you know, that kind of growth rather
than getting all fucking, yeah. Antsy.
Yeah, that's definitely a,
it's definitely a shoe I have like
my wife freaks out about that,
just going like, can you just
sit down and watch TV with me?
And then if I watch TV it becomes
interactive and I'm like talking to it.
And then she's just like, you're ruining
all of my show. And you have to like,
oh yeah, yeah. I mean that's,
yeah, I [inaudible] she's like,
shut up or leave the room
because I can get very, you know,
like parenthood. She loved
parenthood and I get it.
It was a very successful show. But
like, you know, I, I would, yeah,
I would tear it apart. Yeah. Like,
and what do you mean? That's all I do.
She goes, my wife, I met,
she's actually gonna come on the podcast
because she kind of went rogue on me.
You know, there's just, there's a
rule with like recording shows. Yeah.
Where this the a, Hey, I taped the
game. You don't give a shit. Hey,
you got the real housewives.
So who gives a fuck?
I don't care what the good shows.
The Fargo's the better call Saul's,
we got your shower nail. It's like,
you know, these are the odd the shows.
But what this is like with the kid, this
is like our shared family time, right.
Dude, she wants to better call Saul.
Fucking erase the thing. Ah, yeah.
And then tries to go all, you can
go onto a wherever. Wow. Yeah.
Wow. Yes. That's not,
we'll be discussing that.
It's not bringing her
in for that one. Yeah.
I was just sitting there going like way
down. Yeah, like a, what's going on?
Is Sarah, somebody else you
see in here? What's going,
I thought this was like a together
thing. That's how it starts.
That's how it starts.
Yay. Steady racing shows.
Your first hint that there's a problem
with your marriage is the shows you used
to watch together. All of
a sudden it's just like,
like did you just stop taping that?
Did you, wow. No, that was, I'm sorry,
was the Fargo one she,
she watched like the first episode of
the second episode and she just erased,
is it a mistake? Was it because it was
like the lowest priority thing? No, no,
no. It says she has gone rogue in TV.
Wow. Yeah,
and I love that you having that reaction
because this is prime in the pump for
the next, we might call the
next episode. Wow. Wow. Wow.
My wife. Wow. That's so that,
that's why I was looking at it like,
so that's how it is. Yeah. That's
how it is. I guess I'm on my own now.
I said the baby thing, is it the, like
she's, you know, kind of, you know,
she kinda said it was that she was just
like, look, you go out in the road,
you're doing your cakes. It's just
like, I'm a home here. I'm fried. Okay.
I need to look at some adults.
I can only go Google goggles so long and
I am so sleep deprived when you're not
here. Oh my God. You know, I just,
you know, delete. Yes. You know,
robot mode and dead. Oh, did I do
that? That right. Fucking whatever.
Go on Netflix and find it.
Rotate. Getting eight hours sleep.
That's how she looks at it. So, anyways,
so let's, let's get the schedule here.
Okay. You got, you can, where
can they, people watch. Well,
but right now it's just, it's, I
wish, you know, we were on some other,
you know, uh, what do you call that?
The Netflix and the Hulu CSOs and
whatever you say that Amazon, yeah.
Right now cause it's a, it's,
it's, it's its own channel.
So we want to get people, you know, go
to pop, but it's, it's, it's pop TV.
I can go to pop tv.com and throw in your
zip code if you want to find out what
your channel is. But it's,
it's basic for a lot of them.
Sometimes it's a higher tier.
So unfortunately you got it.
You might have to dig a little bit, but
it's on pop TV. A lot of people have it.
It's on all the carriers and I what
nights and Wednesdays at eight 30,
uh, on pop TV and uh, for,
for another five episodes
and a tow to get caught up.
He's trying to make a move.
They pitched him a talk show.
You don't want to do it. Yes.
People get in your head. Yeah.
Now you're doing it. I have and I do.
And people will make no major decisions
without, without your oh scent.
That seems to be a running theme.
Hey, I'm glad I wasn't on that.
Pulling the rug out from
under me at every, every
moment. We got your side kick.
And now we're all caught
up and now they've decided
that it's not going to be a
comedy. No. Then now they're going to go
with this. I'm not funny. She tells me,
I love the reason why it's we
got it now. I figured it out.
You're not funny.
You like to stand up being like going on
stage and like deliberately bombing is
hard. Yeah. If you've been like,
cause you just automatically have
the saver like oh that didn't work.
Let's at least get a chuckle. I my pig,
I did that thing about pixie sticks.
I don't know.
For some reason it was just that
thing like you know that that line,
you know people have an idea
of what standup is and go
to is and for some reason
mine was remember pixie sticks. Yeah.
What's up with the stupid like and you
think it's going to be funny and it's
not. So I just love, I'd never
had a pay off. I mean nothing.
Does anybody need that much sugar? Yeah.
It was just one set up after another
and he just kept fucking going with it.
I was this like, Oh my God, I've
literally been that calm. I'm that is,
that is people's ideas
to everybody has like,
they got the ideas of the boy
bands, they can know which this,
that and the other thing, the ACLU then
when they see the actual work of it. So.
Right. Joey, thanks. Great to have you
man. I really hope I get to work again.
It was great to get to know
you on the heat. Once again,
I apologize for the rug. I'm going to
use it for all it's worth building.
It worked out. This, this here, this
episode was the return of the Mech.
Thank you for coming in and continued
success with things right. Show you too.
Alright.